[Music]
so the united states says it's carried
out a drone strike against isil in
eastern afghanistan the attack in
nangarhar province follows an earlier
warning from president joe biden he said
his forces would hunt down those behind
thursday's suicide bombing outside kabul
airport at least 175 people were killed
including 13 u.s troops
well the u.s embassy in kabul is warning
americans against traveling to the
airport because of security concerns the
pentagon says specific credible threats
against the facility remain
officials say any americans who are
waiting at the airport should leave
immediately the united states and allied
forces are racing to evacuate their
citizens and vulnerable afghans before a
deadline to withdraw troops on tuesday
i will be speaking to charlotte bellas
about the situation in afghanistan in
just a moment but first gabriel elizondo
has more on the drone strike
uh the u.s central command
saying that a drone
attack
strike if you will
hit a isil
k
planner in the words of the u.s central
command
and that the strike was successful and
killed that person
they said this happened in eastern
afghanistan in the nangarhar province
that's province in the eastern part of
the country part of it borders pakistan
they say that there was no civilian
casualties that the u.s military knows
about now the reuters news agency here
in the united states
reporting that
information from unnamed u.s officials
that it was a drone that was uh launched
from a base in the middle east and that
it killed this isil
k planner who was driving a vehicle with
another associate and that both were
killed
we do not know exactly when this
operation took place
and we do also do not know if this is
one of more that are to be expected in
the future
but clearly the united states uh its
first retaliation uh for the attack
outside the kabul airport on thursday
all right let's speak now to charlotte
who's live for us in kabul and charlotte
understand you've just been up to the
airport and as the deadline draws near
i'm wondering who's in control there
yeah so last night we were told by some
taliban contacts that they were moving
more forces inside the airport perimeter
what they were calling their victorious
strike force units which are essentially
like their version of special forces and
that they've moved more of those
personnel inside the airport the us
denied that they had taken control of
the airport fully but we do understand
that they are slowly taking control of
more areas within the actual airport
perimeter and then this morning when we
went down we went to the north side of
the airport because in the last two
weeks that has been controlled by a
cia-run militia they're known as the
zero units and they're associated
obviously closely with the americans and
they had been separating western forces
from the taliban they had told us this
militia that they were going to be
evacuated by the us when this was all
done this morning we went down there
sure enough the taliban had taken
control of the northern perimeter they
said the handover began around 7 a.m
local time we could see pockets of these
zero units
surrounded by taliban and these these
two groups have been arch enemies for
some years now they've been surrounded
and the taliban was slowly taking
control of that stretch so certainly as
this winds down the taliban picking up
more areas of the airport
and what about the evacuations what's
happening there
well there were thousands of people down
there this morning still trying to get
on some of these flights we understand
that they are winding down when we were
down there we could see the tail of a
military aircraft near the tarmac if you
look at flight radar you can still see
c-17s entering and leaving afghan
airspace but fewer military aircraft
than there were in previous days and at
the moment they've evacuated more than
110 000 people whether they'll get uh
huge numbers out in the next couple of
days it doesn't seem so as as this
starts to wind to an end certainly us
allies have started to end their
evacuation efforts the turkish military
for example have said that their
military presence here has come to an
end but they for example are going to
leave a technical team behind to help
the taliban essentially run the airport
as of wednesday when all foreign forces
have left
all right charlotte leave there for the
moment thanks very much charlotte
ballister in kabul
so it's been called a life-altering
storm hurricane ida is making